the hmas adelaide left australia on
friday carrying much needed aid supplies
to tonga but as the ship neared its
destination the australian government
confirmed there had been a covert 19
outbreak on board i can report to you
that uh 23 personnel on hmas adelaide
which departed brisbane
only a matter of days ago
have been have tested positive
with covert 19 there are those people
obviously and others on board who are in
isolation at the moment tonga
desperately needs outside assistance
after the volcanic eruption and tsunami
more than a week ago but doesn't want to
risk an outbreak of covert 19 brought by
aid workers
it's insisting that all supplies must be
delivered contactless
at this stage the adelaide will complete
its mission
as some communication is restored in
tonga more images are coming out showing
how devastating the disaster was
these are from the island of nomuka one
of the closest to the volcano and one of
the most affected
the red cross estimates waves as high as
15 meters smashed into nomuka and nearby
islands really nobody knew that there
was a wave coming
so you know in every household that was
on the road like we just shouted out
tsunami tsunami you know get to higher
ground most people here have been moved
to the main island of tongatapu
there a long cleanup is underway and
power has been restored but livelihoods
in this tiny island nation will take a
long time to rebuild
i have a bakery but i can't even open it
now because of the ash in the bakery and
my home
tonga's economy was already in trouble
before the disaster now the outlook is
even more grim and basic supplies may
become hard to get when we're talking
about crops and farm
it was um severely damaged uh due to the
dust covering the the farms the yams and
in the in the crops we still managed to
survive through with our our our food
imported food we're talking about tin
can
corned beef and
tuna in the short term assistance will
continue to arrive but the tongans will
need long-term help to rebuild and
recover wayne hey al-jazeera tauranga
new zealand